[Música]
foi no meio de uma crise de ansiedade
aparentemente sem motivo algum o que eu
percebi que algo de errado estava
prestes a ter o maior ensinamento da
minha filha pra contar essa história pra
vocês eu preciso voltar um pouco no
tempo mais precisamente quando ainda
muito novo eu decidi abrir meu 1º
negócio
o meu único estágio havia durado ou com
mais de um mês meu imaturo já era
suficiente
soma se a essa imaturidade pouquíssima
experiência e zero clients
esse foi o cenário do meu dia 11
enquanto empreendedor até que as coisas
começassem entrar nos eixos
eu dei muita cabeçada por aí eu mal
sabia o que estava fazendo
se tinha algo que eu nunca duvidei é que
um dia chegaria lá e leia se ter grandes
clientes e sucesso financeiro
eu pude então para 2014 por um momento
que eu apresentava um grande projeto
maior de todos numa sala como essa
repleta de executivos de um dos mais
importantes grupos de comunicação
o sucesso financeiro relativo um grande
cliente e o ego e se devidamente
ilustrado aos olhos de todos
eu tinha chego lá mas o que ninguém
nunca tinha me dito é que o lá ele muda
de lugar quando chega lá eu havia
passado dez anos da minha vida
perseguindo exatamente o que eu estava
vivendo naquele momento mas
estranhamente filme vazio
e o pior é que eu me vi doente uma grave
e forte gastrite nervosa
fruto de uma entrega insana pessoal a
minha empresa
na certeza de que os fins justificariam
os meios
eu me perdi no caminho e era preciso me
reencontrar depois de muito negar o que
estava acontecendo eu defino que é hora
de sair do escritório
eu ajudei a fundar não fazia mais
sentido algum pra mim e eu faço isso
dentro de um prazo de dois anos onde eu
mudo bruscamente a minha vida mudou de
lugar para lugar bem menor
corta os cartões de crédito e até
comprar uma bike
eu já sabia que não queria mais do que
naquele momento foi muito importante mas
eu não tinha a menor idéia do que eu
iria fazer
prontamente eu passei a desenhar novos
laços novos objetivos de onde eu queria
chegar
e foi aí que eu percebi que o buraco era
mais embaixo
ou melhor era mais em cima
era uma questão de formatação mental
dizem que o excesso de passado a
nostalgia mas o meu maior sofrimento
sempre foi jogar a minha mente para uma
unidade de tempo que o meu corpo não
acompanhava o gatilho e o combustível da
minha cidade foi sempre estar vivendo no
futuro o que eu precisava naquele exato
momento era estar presente e ter
consciência ou menos sentir algo que
fizesse algum sentido para mim
ciente que eu precisaria então me
desconstruir para mim construir uma nova
e quem sabe melhorar da versão de mim
mesmo eu entro numa fase da minha vida
que eu chamo de experimentação onde eu
aceitei
quase todos os convites que me foram
feitos e o mais insano de todos talvez
tenha vindo de um grande amigo meu que
eu havia me reconectado por essas
decisões que a vida lhe impôs
queria pedalar mil quilômetros até
montevidéu
eu consegui sentir a alegria e
entusiasmo dele falando sobre isso e
talvez por esse motivo ou por efeito do
vinho quente tomava na hora que eu
decidi que eu iria junto
um detalhe que eu não compartilhei com
ele é que eu sequer pedalava na verdade
que eu não tinha a menor idéia de que eu
estava fazendo o que estava me metendo e
muito menos nós iríamos chegar lá
e de fato eu estava lutando contra essa
necessidade de ter certeza das coisas
nós nos preparamos dez meses pra isso e
depois de dez dias de pedalada muitos
deles na chuva e sem lugar para dormir
mas também passando por lugares
incríveis e principalmente com uma
experiência de vida única transformadora
nós chegamos em montevidéu o sentimento
que eu tive quando me olhei no espelho
do hotel e percebi que eu tinha acabado
de fazer
é indescritível mas teve um fato dessa
história toda que bateu muito forte um
era o último dia próximo a montevidéu e
eu já bastante debilitado
comecei a focar na linha de chegada por
mais que a experiência estivesse sendo
incrível
naquele momento de dor eu só queria
chegar
quanto mais eu mentalizava a isso mais
duro caminho se tornava até que num
determinado momento eu enxergo multi dó
ainda borrado pela distância que a gente
estava e que à medida que a gente foi se
aproximando se tornou mais nítido
era a frase de um cara chamado ruan
avarias
eu não acreditei quando finalmente
consegui ler o que dizia nesse outdoors
em letras garrafais dizia nunca se liga
só nós e progresso numa tradução rápida
e nunca x nunca se chega só se progresso
a primeira coisa que eu pensei foi que
foi engraçado que botou isso aqui g
eu queria chegar mas de alguma forma
isso fez com que eu tirasse um pouco o
foco da linha de chegada e passasse a me
conectar mas com o meu contexto e o que
me cercava e isso me deu forças para que
a gente chegasse até o momento de
artigas em montevidéu que foi o destino
final dessa travessia que separou porto
alegre e montevidéu
ao retornar para o brasil obviamente que
procurar a história desse cara
nascido na periferia de montevidéu
ruan tinha se tornado um grande golfista
ele tinha chegado lá
mas como a gente já sabe o lado dele
também mudou de lugar em uma tentativa
de assalto em 2016 ele foi baleado e
precisa recomeçar
toda essa experiência fez com que eu
passasse a valorizar muito mais o
processo do que ficar seriamente
pensando na linha de chegada
isso não significa deixar a vida me
levar
ter objetivos é sim importante e eles
dizem que é mais ou menos por aqui que
tudo deve seguir mas consciente do que o
que separa o ponto há o momento presente
do ponto b
o momento futuro não é uma linha reta
eu costumo dizer que tem um objetivo é
como usar uma bússola
ela aponta direção que deve seguir mas
ela não te diz como será o caminho muito
menos os desafios que irá encontrar
e essa é a graça da história a beleza
está no processo
toda vez que eu vou entrar no novo ou
numa nova jornada e eu costumo entrar em
algumas eu me faço uma simples pergunta
eu vou me fazer ouvir gastar é estranho
né
mas a pergunta é eu vou sair dela sendo
uma versão melhor de mim mesmo do que eu
era quando eu entrei e foi respondendo
positivamente esse questiono esse
questionamento que eu decidi então
entrar num novo ou usado
e para muitos insano desafio cruzar os
estados unidos de costa a costa e de
bike é claro
como toda a trama como toda a jornada
transformadora
não foram poucos os motivos os desafios
e os problemas que nos fizeram quase
desistir e eles começaram muito antes de
nós
chegaram nos estados unidos em março
deste ano
subitamente eu perdi meu pai sem aviso
prévio e sem a chance de me despedir e
isso foi muito duro para mim eu decido
então usar essa força essa dor e
transformar em energia para seguir em
frente
a pouco menos de 60 dias da largada nos
faltava dinheiro nos faltava tempo e
mais do que isso nos faltava lógica
nessa história toda
as pessoas nos diziam para desistir as
mais otimistas para tentarmos no ano que
vem
confiantes e entregues ao processo
nós chegamos nos estados unidos e no dia
15 de junho deste ano a medida mais
precisamente de um ensolarado dia na
califórnia
nós partimos pra jornada mais sem noção
das nossas vidas nos primeiros dias nós
não conseguimos nem acreditar no que a
gente estava vivendo
era uma experiência indescritível os
lugares que antes passavam eram surreais
mas sempre tem um mas né
logo no terceiro dia acontece algo que
ninguém estava esperando e eu caí foi a
de ser uma gelada montanha no colorado
que ao perder o controle da bike
eu fui de encontro ao solo a mais de 50
quilômetros por hora
e parecia e se o fim breve dessa
incrível jornada mas não foi
horas depois de sair da ala de
emergência do hospital e vejo subindo a
mais alta montanha de toda a travessia e
ao chegar no topo dos três mil trezentos
e oito metas e cercado por uma natureza
exuberante
eu me senti parte
de tudo aquilo e nesse ponto eu tive a
certeza de que nada mais nos pararia os
5 mil quilômetros que separam ocean side
na califórnia de anápolis e marilan
foram feitos em nove dias sete horas e 8
minutos
um revezamento de 24 horas por dia sem
parar
a parte mais interessante dessa história
toda é que nós não vimos a linha de
chegada
nós literalmente passamos reto por ela e
se não fosse uma fiscal que lá nos
aguardava nos avisar
nós sequer teríamos visto a já apagada
linha branca no chão da sala
nós descemos tiramos foto abraçamos a
fiscal mas nós seguimos em frente
o nosso lar ele não estava mais lá ele
estavam os 15 quilômetros pra frente
aonde a nossa equipe nos aguardava para
comemorar conosco
a verdade é que nós nunca fizemos isso
pela linha de chegada
nós nos preparamos mais de 27 meses para
essa travessia e nós tivemos um
propósito muito claro que blindou todo
esse processo nós fomos lá para inspirar
a impactar o maior número de pessoas
comuns a buscar em seus sonhos e
principalmente a valorizarem o processo
dessa busca sim pessoas comuns daquelas
que perduram boleto na geladeira que
acordam cedo e dormem tarde para
sustentarem a si ou a suas famílias que
têm problemas como todos nós mas aquelas
pessoas que sabem que a vida não é só
isso
moroso processo cotidiano automatizado
até o dia em que chegaremos ao único e
definitivo lá e que ninguém aqui vai
escapar que a nossa morte
eu espero que falte muito tempo ainda e
que eu me auto governe até lá mas quando
esse momento chegar
eu posso olhar para trás para mim a
jornada e tenho certeza que eu fui
verdade
comigo mesmo e que até lá eu siga
aprendendo com a caminhada consciente
que são os meios que justificam o fim
jamais o contrário obrigado
[Aplausos]